Back to our networking diagram.
So the HTTP request will include
the URL we just talked about along with
other bits of information, such as what
action we want to perform on the data,
information about the device,
making a request, and more.
The whole request gets
packaged up together.
It's like sticking
a message in an envelope.
The HTTP request is like an envelope
with a destination and a return address.
After the request is packaged, Android
offers functionality to help a sender
message over the network
to the correct web server.
We haven't officially defined
the word network yet, but
you can think of it as
a digital postal service.
A network is really just two or
more computers connected in some
way that let's them communicate.
And when I say computer, I mean
any computing device like a phone,
laptop or a server.
The internet is a large scale network
consisting of many computers around
the world.
And we can use the HTTP
protocol to route our request
from one computer to the other.
To communicate to a computer on
a different location, we must establish
communication channel, also known as a
network connection, across the internet.
Then we can exchange messages
with the other computer.
In this diagram, we've represented
USGS as a single computer, but
keep in mind that they
have a lot of data.
So they probably have a whole group
of computers who are responding to
requests.
A single computer wouldn't be able to
handle requests from all over the world
for the US geological data.
At this point,
I want to introduce you to some more
formal terminology
that you'll often hear.
You can refer to the USGS
computers that are providing data
as the USGS Web Server.
A web server is simply another
computer or a group of computers on
a network running a program
that responds to HTTP requests.
On the other hand, your phone can
be referred to as the client.
The client requests the information
from the server and
then displays the results to the user.
Often, many different clients would
be connected to the same server, but
each client may display
the data in different ways.
For example, a mobile client may show
information that is more convenient to
viewing in a small mobile screen.
A web client on a desktop, for instance,
might show more detailed information
taking full advantage of
the larger screen size.
Each client sends out
a request to the server.
When the web server receives the
request, it may compose an HTML web page
to return to the sender for display,
or it might return structured data
that we can use in an app we're building
in a format such as JSON or XML.
Once the clients receive
the response from the server,
they control how the data
gets displayed to the users.
For example, a web browser can
render a web page to the screen or
a mobile app can parse out the bits
of data that it needs to show useful
information on the device screen.
In this lesson, we'll zoom in on major
steps for the data exchange process.
First, we'll talk about how
to form a proper HTTP request
based on the information we want and
from where we want to get it.
Second, we'll send the request to
the server, which will process it and
figure out a proper
response to send back.
Third, we'll talk about how the client
can process or parse this response and
convert it into a format
that it understands.
Then lastly, we can update the UI in our
app to show the results to the user.
Before we get into the details
of networking, though,
there's one constraint on the Android
device that we need to deal with first.